3ポイント一番か言ったら上手くなるのー
これじゃあ肇社長です次でまたバカ企画でございます私はじめシャツ osho 通行
大学サークルもうちょっとだけバスケやってるんですけどもバスケットボールって結局
3ポイントが一番ポイント高いです普通の集団にでなんですけども3ポイントは3点
入るつまりバスケットボールは簡単
3ポイントさえ入れるようになればどの試合でも多分勝てますだけどポジション
でに3ポイントを打つタイプじゃないんですけども今回3ポイント1万回練習したら
パンッ
nger どれぐらい一番街練習したらうまくなるのかちょっと行ってみたいと思い
ます色んな場所を転々便りもぅ一箇所で確実にそこ入るように座談会でしたけどこれ
ショッカーヤ90代目で美味しいマジで傷いったかっきー社務局立候補
んですよあとボードがないよ
過去にしますいや俺は家だったらやばい予防
まず練習前ですでいきますだではないと思っても
ん
分
me
ni
じゃあもう一次で一番影だけじゃなくてこつこつとやって一番回やって最後どうなるの
か100発100週になったら
nbi と言いませはまだ研究でれたねーん
[音楽]
ben ん
ん
pm
[音楽]
aveda ドライブってまずシュートフォームをしっかり確認してきます
多分めちゃくちゃ飲んでいま
ええええええ
うーん
me
はっはっはっはっはひっ
今日はここまで馬置けないぞ
[音楽]
ん
ああああーーん
deni
re ほとん
me
家ございました
それを是非病はございません
遠いは腕が遠いは続くだと1階ですね
ん
[音楽]
me
たことです
えっ
えっああああああああ
me
もう少しあった
うんなんか使うが使うの誓ったこんな日
おっ
me
ん
はいえー
持った
a
何かあっん
いろん
ん
[音楽]
ano ang
100かいでー
見解なんだろうなんかシュートフォームがパパからなんでしょうね入る時も打った瞬間
わかるんですよ
この動きが来たっていうするいかにものにできるかとしっかりと安定して同じフォーム
で打っていればもう a に入るはずです
もう100回減ります
[音楽]
バッハ
あった
tan
ame
多分じゃない
これ腕の問題流れ腕の問題えっ
版力が足りんだ
釣り遠いを100回あたりでも腕がダメって言ってたような
とりあえず今日は200をやります
んん
ni
me
パート
[音楽]
dj
ええええええ
ban
me
ran
j yeah
me
よああああ
今発生花今の衛兵にフィリピンルソン島は
[音楽]
ben
ああああああ
ん
done
[音楽]
ni
分
me
うんうん
rar
yeah
ああああああ
ん
分
20くらいから腕がながらこれ慣れていくしかないねずにちょっとまた2で稼いでき
ます
でを201回目です続きます
ええええええ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
4日
wh
me
新穂ワークウォール2
car
[音楽]
wh
ええええええ
あった
[音楽]
ええええええ
ああああああ
dai
me
はい
はいえーい
[拍手]
me
勝ちましたこれで日酔いからです
ええええええ
ああああああ
ai ん
アイ600立ちました筋肉痛が11ですねちょっと慣れるまで
頻度やっぽい感じになると応援でまずあの筋力を叱りつける10日ですねちょっと
変わっています
ああああああ
ないよん
ああ
wh
car
701回目です
uh
dj
[音楽]
ああああああ
car
wh
[音楽]
ああああああ
car
me
ああああああああ
ます
wh
の
me
はぁ ana
分
ああああああああ
n 取ったよ
[音楽]
ああああああああ
ん
ええええええええええええええええええ
ベガん
car だっていいいい
me
ん
ai
pane
me
ます
[音楽]
deai
あああああ
4日目て千本つありました10番目でどれくらい変わったか十本チューナーも入った体
目当てで行ってみたいと思います今
日本
ん
ええええええ
[音楽]
ん
tan tan
done
今子です b ロックです
[音楽]
n
ni
rar
あああああ
tan
2を2つん
10分ったもんでした頑張ります
[音楽]
car
ええええええ
[音楽]
[拍手]
par
はっはっは
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
mai
います
3本
休日で400ぷったんですけど後半が負うデラッ
音がユニークだ靴を置く人っていう中身あれば張りすぎて
春えっええええええ
分
me
ん
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
入って5-2
さあ
par 5
を張って
mai
ん
15001回目伊豆金利ちょっとついてきて軽い力で届くようになってきたような気も
しません
ええええええ
[音楽]
goo
[拍手]
rar
ええええええ
yeah
[音楽]
ええええええ
wh
バジェットダメ
rar
par
あっはっは
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
th
ああああああ
あるああああああ
tar
ana
[音楽]
名だたる
はぁ
うわあああああああ
あああああ
に精一投目
scala でございます
[音楽]
wh
ああああああああああああ
ええええええ
は6 aa
ああああああ
ああああああああ
ん
ええええええええええええ
japan
ton
ええええええ
car
yeah
ええええええ
wh
ああああああ
goo
aa uh
me
t 2 j バグ1
ええええええ
ます
ni
car
tan
th
ああああああああああああ
[音楽]
tai
wh
[音楽]
さあああああああああああ
wh
3000懸命
car
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
th
ああああああ
wh
[音楽]
bejean
me
ええええええ
ああああああ
ni
ああああああああああああ
me
car
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
car
ええええええ
[音楽]
def
4勢一
ませんでさ
[音楽]
ええええええ
dee
th
tee
[音楽]
カフェバッハ
dee
ブーブーますよ始めましですよ
3ポイント1番号パティ今4700本プロスカー
あったら言ってくださいあるが何いやもうなかったですよね
賠償だけ練習してくれればずいずいたが大きいですよろしくお願い致します
では4701
ん
他の
8分0
たが3枚ずつけど
た内側はいいけないでございます
tan
を打たずに
[音楽]
ん
足を送っている
ですから
理由ん
すごいプロだったはぁっ
クイーンなぁ
どうぞ
nia 位
ええええええ
ana
wh
4日
ええええええ
[音楽]
ああああああ
投薬のアドバイスでめっちゃ入った瞬間優しく優しく
呼び
白ちょっと目ギアスでないようにまずで曲はサーレーどうぞ字拝領する
今日1901あと100本で5000回ですちょっと集中して100本ていきましょう
[音楽]
ええええええ
はいというわけで打ち5千本の3ポイントを打ち終わりました
体幹やっぱりまた波があるというか入る時はめっちゃ入るよねー
なんか決まる時はまずで3つ入るんですけどたまにばスランプっていうか入れない時が
あるんで other 安定はしてないんですけども
プレちょっと5000回打った後の私のせいか十本チューナーも入るか
みてください一発勝できます
良いん
[音楽]
[拍手]
ええええええ
すごいん
はい
何がありましたね入る時3年付とから入ってるんですけど
入んなくなったらほんと突然乱れてリングに当たらない時とかあるんで
もうちょっと残りの光線会で精度を上げていきたいとおもいます
ええええええ
to do
ああああああああああああ